[music playing]
MAN (OVER RADIO):
[inaudible] 200 meters.
Pisces V, K OK, do you copy?
Roger, hatch is shut, ready
to dive, dive, dive, over.
MAN (OVER RADIO):
Roger, hatch is shut,
ready to dive, dive, dive.
NARRATOR: Sylvia last dived
here nearly four decades ago,
using a special diving
suit called JIM.
REPORTER: There is a
new tool in the sea.
It moves with the
ponderous rhythms
of a mechanical monster.
Her question, can scientists
use the JIM suit for dives
beyond 1,000 feet?
If successful, she will be the
first woman to walk the sea
floor beyond 1,000 feet.
SYLVIA EARLE: I see it.
Oh, it's the bottom!
NARRATOR: Sylvia is looking
for signs of change.
When you're up
near the surface,
it's kind of light blue.
But as you go down, you see
the pretty shades of blue.
And the blue gets
darker and darker.
Then it get pitch black.
It's like a different world.
Yeah.
SYLVIA EARLE: Actually, our
world is a different world.
This is normal.
NARRATOR: New life
comes to light.
An unknown coral.
Chris doesn't even know
what species this thing is.
CHRIS: is the only place I've
really seen it this color.
I've seen some in
northwestern Hawaiian islands.
Oh yeah, just scattered.
It's everywhere.
This is like a magic carpet.
Oh, my goodness.
Beautiful.
Except it's better
than any old carpet.
It's alive.
It's a live flying carpet.
Sylvia never stopped
looking out the window.
She's just excited to see things
that hadn't seen in so long.
SYLVIA EARLE: Swimming
right under the ray.
FINN KENNEDY: The ray
just ate something.
He just trapped some of
those little fish under his.
That's unbelievable, he did.
He got one of those polymixia.
MAN (OVER RADIO): Pisces
V, Pisces IV, do you copy?
We just watched these
two rays eat polymixia.
SYLVIA EARLE: Here
comes the ray.
MAN (OVER RADIO): OK,
that's the first observation
I've heard anybody say that.
That's really interesting.
SYLVIA EARLE: Took a
kid with fresh eyes
to notice something that has
been happening all along.
Because after Finn
pointed it out,
we looked and we saw it
happening all around us.
That little eel
just swam under.
Oh, did you see?
FINN KENNEDY: Yeah,
I got it on film.
Oh.